my favorite part about uh coach probably
being my coach you can learn a lot teach
you about different things it ain't only
about football like I'm going to his
office and we just sat there and talked
for like two hours you can learn a lot
from just going in there talking to him
I mean he's always there no matter what
so that's what I like the most I mean he
teach me a lot on the field every day he
teaches me something different something
that I didn't do the day before some
that he didn't see because it's always
good learning from her great dude and I
know he got a lot of connections to the
NFL long as I do my part he's going to
do his part so just got to believe